el maestro de vivek y de camila les dio
un sistema de ecuaciones lineales para
resolver cada uno realizó algunos pasos
que condujeron a los sistemas que se
muestran en la tabla de abajo aquí
tenemos al del maestro de vivek y de
camila cuál de ellos obtuvo un sistema
equivalente al sistema del maestro así
que la primera pregunta que yo te tengo
en este vídeo es que es un sistema
equivalente y para saber qué es un
sistema equivalente vamos a leer lo que
dice acá abajo recuerda que dos sistemas
lineales son equivalentes si tienen la
misma solución es decir que si después
de resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
que tiene el maestro obtengo un par xy
qué solución de este para que el sistema
sea equivalente entonces debo de tener
la misma solución que la solución del
maestro es decir que si este sistema es
equivalente al del maestro el sistema de
vivek entonces el par x ya que tenga
como solución vibe que debe ser igual
al par xy que tenga el maestro y lo
mismo para camila que tengan la misma
solución así vamos a fijarnos en este
sistema el del maestro y en el sistema
de vivek para ver si son o no
equivalentes bueno lo primero de lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que nuestra
primera ecuación es exactamente la misma
por lo tanto es así cumple que vamos a
obtener la misma solución porque
cualquier solución que yo obtenga aquí
va a cumplir también esta misma ecuación
porque bueno pues porque son la misma y
bueno vamos a fijarnos en nuestra
segunda ecuación si te fijas en esta
segunda ecuación te vas a dar cuenta que
no hay forma de escalar esta ecuación
para llegar a esta otra ecuación y esto
es porque si yo quiero multiplicar al 1
para llegar al 0 tendré que
multiplicarlo por 0 entonces me quedaría
1 x 0 0 y del lado izquierdo pues todo
esto me quedaría también cero porque 0
por lo que sea me va a dar 0 entonces
llegaría de igualdad 0 es igual a cero
así que no podemos escalar por ambos
lados para llegar de una ecuación a la
otra así que vamos a ver si podemos
hacer alguna otra operación bueno se me
ocurre que
pudo haber sumado restado por algo para
llegar a esta de aquí así que vamos a
intentarlo
imagínate que empezamos con esta que es
menos 4 x más 5 y igual a 1 y queremos
llegar a menos 3 x + 7 y igual a cero
vamos a ver si podemos llegar por acá
entonces déjame poner una pequeña línea
para acá otra por acá y vamos a ver que
tuvo que haber sumado o restado para
llegar a esta de menos 4 x para menos 3
x lo que tuvo que haber hecho es haber
sumado x estás de acuerdo a de 5 para 7
y lo que tuvo que haber hecho es sumado
2 y fíjate es esta parte de aquí y
después tengo de 1 para llegar a 0 tuvo
que haber restado 1 que justo aquí
tenemos menos 1 así que fíjate lo que
pasó él tomó las dos partes izquierdas
de esta ecuación para obtener la parte
izquierda de esta ecuación y sumó las
dos partes
de estas dos ecuaciones para obtener la
parte derecha de esta ecuación y de
hecho esta es una operación legítima en
este caso esta esta recta que estamos
obteniendo aquí es distinta a esta recta
que teníamos en un principio pero el
sistema resultante va a tener la misma
solución bueno y porque estamos tan
seguros de esto es que por cada par x y
que sea solución de este sistema pues va
a cumplir tanto la primera como la
segunda así que estoy sumando de ambos
lados lo mismo porque es solución voy a
sumar del lado izquierdo x + 2 justo
aquí a esta parte izquierda de esta
ecuación pero si yo lo que quiero es no
alterar esta igualdad tengo que hacer lo
mismo del otro lado de la ecuación ahora
como nos estamos fijando en la solución
cuando yo pongo mi solución en x + 2 y
me va a dar menos 1 por lo tanto estamos
sumando lo mismo de ambos lados de esta
ecuación por lo tanto como estoy sumando
lo mismo de ambos lados entonces me da
nueva recta la cual no va a cambiar no
va a alterar la solución de mi sistema
así que lo que hizo vivek fue una
operación correcta lo que hizo fue tomar
el lado izquierdo de estas dos
ecuaciones lineales y también el lado
derecho de estas dos ecuaciones lineales
lo sumo y me dio esta nueva ecuación
lineal pero el sistema solución va a ser
el mismo y de hecho esta es una técnica
que a veces se usa para sacar la
solución de un sistema de ecuaciones así
que en este caso vamos bien ahora
pensemos en camila bueno lo primero de
lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
su primera ecuación es exactamente igual
que la segunda ecuación del maestro por
lo tanto hasta ahí vamos bien ahora
vamos a fijarnos en su segunda ecuación
y compararla con la primera ecuación del
maestro y si te das cuenta parece ser
que lo que hizo fue multiplicar por un
cierto número esta ecuación para llegar
a esta otra es decir que tomó la primera
ecuación del profesor y multiplicó por
algo
para llegar a la segunda ecuación de
camila y si nos fijamos en el lado
derecho de la ecuación del maestro a
comparación de la ecuación de camila lo
que hizo fue multiplicar por menos 8 es
decir menos 1 x menos 8 me va a dar 8
positivo y si ahora nos fijamos en
nuestro lado izquierdo vamos a ver qué
pasa si yo me tomo este lado izquierdo y
lo multiplicó también por menos 8 parece
ser que si llegamos al lado izquierdo de
la ecuación de camila
veamos x x menos 8 me da menos 8x y 2 x
menos 8 me va a dar menos 16 y está de
lujo es la misma recta lo único que hizo
fue multiplicar por medios 8 está parece
tal vez una ecuación distinta pero lo
único que hicimos fue multiplicar por
menos 8 por lo tanto es exactamente la
misma recta en definitiva este sí es un
sistema equivalente porque tenemos la
misma construcción y vamos a tener
entonces la misma solución cuando tú
estás trabajando con un sistema no vas a
cambiar su solución si multiplicas ambos
lados de la ecuación por un mismo
escalar o
si tú sumas o restas las dos ecuaciones
y cuando me refiero a sumar o a restar
las dos ecuaciones me refiero a que tú
sumas y restas el lado derecho de tus
dos ecuaciones y el lado izquierdo de
tus dos ecuaciones como en el caso que
tuvimos aquí o también podrías restarlo
no sé supongamos restar nuestra segunda
ecuación de la primera si nosotros
restamos los lados izquierdos y los
lados derechos vamos a llegar a
exactamente un sistema que tenga la
misma solución por lo tanto estos dos
casos tanto vivek como camila son
sistemas equivalentes son sistemas
equivalentes al sistema del maestro